originaux nous les avons tous en notre
possession fort de titre de propriété au
nom de leur père et grand-père salomé
equi décédé le 20 novembre 1976 ses
héritiers s'engage dans une procédure
juridique qui risque d'être longue
cette économe de profession n'avait que
36 ans lorsqu'il aurait fait
l'acquisition de plusieurs hectares de
terres à cette main est là trois types
de propriétés deux types de produits de
1925 un titre de propriété de 1928
d'accord donc l'occupant lui il occupe
ses terres avec aussi un petit de
probité par contre nous nos titres de
propriété ils issus d'autres titres de
propriété qui sont en notre possession
notamment à 2913 d'accord alors que
l'occupant lui il s'appuie sur un lac
fort de tous ces éléments là nous avons
informé le que dans ce litige
les oppose aux consorts simonette et à
la haye c'est ce qu'a fait hier ses
derniers espoirs depuis des lustres
plusieurs hectares de bananes ici au
quartier perron il revendique d aussi la
propriété de ses parcelles
moi j'ai un type de propriété qui date
de 1923
mon grand père andré schindler et faire
qu'ils ont dans l'ensemble de terre
sainte marie et ses titres comme vous le
savez le cadre at le cadastre est
intervenu en martinique au début des
années soixante et onze et est depuis
donc 1923 ma famille est propriétaire
des terres revendiquées visiblement par
là par les consoles wii le 3 septembre
dernier les consorts et guy has in
devant un tribunal de grande instance de
fort-de-france les consorts simonette
reste cependant à déterminer le volume
exact de ses propriétés comme ce sont
des titres effectivement des titres
anciens dont réticents siens ont parlé
de borner aux herbes du vent donc notre
objectif aujourd'hui c'est de redéfinir
le cadre est de poser un cadre avec que
basique que sur des faits le tribunal de
grande instance devra effectivement se
trouve non c'est sur la propriété du
mois si le tribunal de grande instance
considère que les conseils d'une en
raison d' à écouter le tribunal est
souvent c'est pas moi qui déciderai
il ya des instances compétentes ont vu
j'ai deux pieds propriétaire qui n'est
pas propriétaire
les documents note reconnaît en notre
nom notre possession je vous le dis
la peste que nous sommes propriétaires
de façon continue depuis qu'ils ne sont
pas voilà constitue aujourd'hui en
association les consorts aiguilles
bénéficie du soutien de la soupe a marre
je pense qu'il faut que cette situation
se règle au plus vite pour que les
écuries puissent retrouver voiture et
retrouver leurs droits à retrouver leur
terre ce litige défraie la chronique de
le nom atlantique
les juges devront donc vérifier
l'authenticité des actes notariés des
deux parties afin d'apaiser les tensions
à sept maris